what is the greatest TV show theme song
I'll give you some choices one of the
greatest theme songs of all time
my Brice thing that would that choir in
here yes moving on to the east
[Applause]
[Music]
which I do the other lyrics right
it's Gilligan's Island better if you're
talking about a TV theme song that sets
up the show and tells the story then
Gilligan's Island I mean that's that's
one of the top but here's why the
Jeffersons is better I'll tell you why
it's catchy ER and people sang it right
[Music]
see how you're bopping your head John
that's why it might be better don't get
me wrong but everybody knows the works
the Gilligan's Island what about the
Monkees theme song that's a good one I'm
trying to think what is the best
then they got that drumroll right here
[Music]
I was pretty good alright right now it's
between the monkeys or The Jeffersons
The Jeffersons I think I'm with you on
that I think I'm with you on that too
and it tells his story movin on up to
the east side to a deluxe apartment in
the sky right you know what else was
good Welcome Back Kotter was a pretty
good John Sebastian rock company and
sang
[Music]
welcome back I mean that became a huge
pop - no but we're talking TV theme song
[Music]
for the show every time or this classic
lurch in the middle of it which is
awesome
what is lurch saying it neat sweet
petite yeah yeah I gotta get to that
part the teeth lurch was this [__] there
you go what about the Batman theme no no
that was pretty good it was
[Music]
it's right to the point I like pow
they're doing all that cartoon
I wonder who the guy is who plays
trumpet on the right in that opening
there he goes
something simply punching someone in the
face Batman
I like because I could memorize the
words
[Music]
that's fine just lazy I could write this
Batman
you know the guy who wrote Addams Family
also wrote Green Acres that was a great
theme song life for me like when she
goes I get allergic smelling hay but not
better than the Jeffersons yeah what do
you got to say Ralph I was going to say
you didn't have Batman but Fred just
corrected that now yeah but I raised
lunch
Dukes of Hazzard do they have a good
thing who is that Waylon Jennings that's
a good one
look I have to admit that's when I knew
women were as bad as men because I
watched that show every week just to see
those guys asses there that one in the
daisy dukes what was her name again
Catherine Bach they said about that show
you either looked at her or you looked
at the guys really the car but nobody
paid attention to what happened during
that time you know what the show is
about all right where was I I mean
reminder what
all right here's a great theme song but
is it better than the Jefferson already
hello I'm mister and of course this was
pretty great doctor what horse of course
that is of course unless the horse is
the famous mystery not as good as the
Jeffersons this is perhaps one of the
best ones ever written up through the
ground came upon the land
[Music]
first thing you know what Jays a
millionaire in folks and gently move the
[__] away California well anyway I have
now proven the theory that the
Jeffersons might have been the greatest
theme song of all time I just like how
we all know hundreds of television oh I
could do this all day